SANDRO GALEA: Well,
thank you very much.
Thank you, everybody
for being here,
and thank you for joining both
in person and on the sites
all over the world.
So let me just talk a
little bit about myself
by way of introduction.
Then I'll talk about the book.
I'm a physician by training.
And then I did academic public
health training as well as
Chris mentioned.
And it was-- sometimes
I'm asked how long it
took me to write this book,
and the answer is 20 years.
It didn't actually take
20 years to write a book.
It took about six months.
But it builds on about 20
years worth of thoughts
and experience in the field.
And really, the earliest
motivation for this book
came from when I was
working in Somalia,
which Chris
mentioned I was doing
with Doctors Without Borders.
And I was very much doing
sort of hands-on clinical work
day to day and helping
people and helping people
and helping people.
And while I was
there, I couldn't
help but feel like I was the
proverbial guy on the side
of the river, pulling
somebody out of the river
as she's drowning, and then
jumping in and pulling out
somebody else because
he's drowning,
then jumping and pulling
somebody else out of the river
because she's drowning, but
never stopping for a second
and saying, who is throwing
them in the river to begin with?
And recognizing that, I think I
started my path down this road
over the past 20 years trying
to better understand what
is it that really causes health.
How is it that I can go
upstream and understand
what drives health so that we
can keep people healthy for as
long as possible?
And what this book
tries to do is
it tries to say
what causes health
and how do we change the
conversation on health
so that we can actually
create a healthier world?
Because at the end of today--
I talk to audiences all
the time, blue audiences,
red audiences, purple
audiences, and it's very clear
that we all care about health.
We may disagree on any number of
values, but all over the world,
everybody would like to
be healthy as possible,
would like their children to
be as healthy as possible,
and would like to see
their children grow up
and get married and them
being healthy as possible.
So the book is called "Well--
What We Need to Talk About
When We Talk About Health,"
because I've become convinced
that at the end of the day,
we need a different
conversation on health,
and we need to talk about
health differently in such a way
that it changes how
we approach health.
I'm going to show you a couple
of data slides that frames
the issue starting from the
point of why our health is not
as good as it should be.
Now I'm going to make this
a US-centric presentation,
the first part of
it, just because I'm
focusing on US data, but
I'm happy to talk about
in the global
context afterwards.
But let me then move on to this
first question, which is really
what is wrong with our health.
Like if I'm here
telling you that we
need to talk about our
health differently,
it's reasonable to ask me, well,
there must be something wrong
with our health,
otherwise, the way
we're talking about our
health is just fine.
So let me show you
one simple slide that
captures that, which is this.
So this is death from
non-communicable diseases,
which is things like
cancer and heart disease.
And what you see
here is a number
of high income countries.
You have Japan, Spain, Italy,
Norway, Sweden, and the United
States is in red.
Now this is one
slide, one data slide.
But I could show you--
I could spend the
next half an hour
showing you data slide
after data slide that
makes this exact same
point, essentially
that health indicators
in the United States
are worse than they are in all
other high income countries.
It's consistent on
life expectancy,
consistent on mortality
rate, and it's
consistent across
all age groups,
just to make that point.
So what this graph is is looking
at age groups on the x-axis.
So you see, you go
from left to right,
you're starting with
newborns and infants
and children, young
adolescents, older adolescents,
young adults, older adults.
And you see two
things on this graph.
So first of all, you
see a U-shaped curve.
And this is mortality.
So the U-shaped
curve makes sense,
because the healthiest years
of life are young adulthood.
So late adolescence,
young adulthood
is when people die the least.
So that makes sense.
But then I want you to look at
the blue bar and the red bar.
The blue bar is our
mortality in the US,
and the red bar is all
other high income countries.
And what you see is
that the blue bar
is higher than the red
bar at every age group.
So in the US context, we
are consistent in that we
kill more newborns, infants,
children, young children,
early adolescents, late
adolescents, young adults,
middle age adults
at every age group.
So in some respects, the US
is consistent that way in that
it has worse health than all
its peer countries consistently.
Now, I find that well-informed,
educated audiences
tend to know this, that
there is a bit of a sense
that American health is not
all it's cracked up to be.
And in audiences like this one,
which is a worldwide audiences,
you typically tend to
have a sense of well,
we understand that
this is actually
becoming a challenge in
all high income countries.
And this is a problem.
And we tend to approach this
problem a bit of a shrug,
I find.
Like we're just not
so good at health.
But I think that
approach is incorrect.
And we need to be
cognizant of something that
is sort of quite
important, which
is it was not always
like this, that actually
this decrement in health is a
relatively recent phenomenon.
So this is a graph going back
to past almost 40 years now
from 1980 on.
And this is life expectancies.
This is how long people
can expect to live.
And what you see is
the red dot is the US,
and the gray dots are other
high income countries.
So as recently as 1980,
which is 35 to 40 years ago,
the US life expectancy
was actually
in the top half of all
high income countries.
And you see that over
the past 35 years,
it has drifted to the bottom.
So what we have come to accept
with a bit of a shrug, which
is that our health is worse than
other high income countries,
that our health is
not what it should be,
wasn't always like that.
And in fact, it is
a set of conditions
that we have created
that has brought it here,
because I would ask you this,
what has changed in the past 40
years?
Certainly, our genetics
have not changed.
So it must be the rest of the
set of conditions around us
that ultimately
are driving what's
making our health worse than
it was as recently as 35,
40 years ago.
Now, to be optimistic, from a
glass half full point of view,
if we've made our health
worse in the past 35,
40 years, we can
certainly make it better
if we understand what makes our
health worse and reverse it.
As this has happened,
as the US life
expectancy has sort
of trundled along,
many countries have passed us.
So this shows Japan and
Singapore and Chile and Costa
Rica have passed the
US in life expectancy.
It's, for example, not
well understood in the US
that Slovenian life expectancy
is higher than it is in the US.
Not just that, life
expectancy in Slovenia
is actually higher than
the life expectancy
of the state in the US with
the highest life expectancy,
which is, by the way, Hawaii.
So Hawaii is the
place you want to be
if you want to live longest.
I don't know if people are in
Hawaii watching this digitally.
But even Hawaii
has life expectancy
that is less than Slovenia,
not to mention the states that
are down in the lower half.
So we have, as a country,
created worse health
than all other countries.
Now, you might say, well, maybe
we don't care about health.
I started at the
beginning by saying
that health is a universal
value, that we care
about health, and it's
reasonable for you to say,
well, maybe we don't care
so much about health.
Maybe it's OK.
Maybe it's OK that American
health is doing worse,
and people are willing
to accept that.
But I would argue
that the evidence
suggests that's not true.
We actually were not
willing to accept that,
because we are more and more
beginning to recognize this.
This is our life expectancy
compared to other countries.
And what you see is the
blue bar is when we were
gaining in life expectancy.
You see that until
the late '80s.
And the red bars are we've
been losing a life expectancy.
So we were gaining, and now
we've been consistently losing.
And you say, well,
OK, that's fine.
That's fine.
It's how it is.
And there are other things.
We have other priorities.
But that's not what
the data suggests.
This is the money that
we throw at the problem.
So the green bar is
our spending on health.
The other gray lines that are
very faint are other countries,
and the blue line is the average
of other high income countries.
So what you see
is we are spending
40% more on the next closest
competitor on health,
and the slope of change is
steeper than other countries.
So right now, the US health
economy is $3.3 trillion.
1 in 8 Americans
work in health, which
is a higher ratio than any
of these other countries.
So we are spending far more
money than all other countries,
and we are getting
much less out of it.
And sometimes the
challenge I pose
audiences, which I'll
pose to the audience
both here in person
and digitally,
name one other
sector where we spend
40% more than our next
closest competitor
and where our
indicators are worse.
Let me ask you this question.
Would any of you own a US made
smartphone if it cost 40% more
and it performed 40% less?
Well, you wouldn't.
Would you own a car?
Would you own a house?
Like, we actually would not
accept that kind of transaction
in anything else, but somehow,
we accept it on health.
So the argument is we
shouldn't accept this.
This is wrong.
This is simply wrong, and
it should be unacceptable.
And the reason it's
not unacceptable,
which is the
premise of the book,
is that we have not
wrapped our brain
around thinking about
health properly,
that to make this
unacceptable, we
need to start thinking about
health in the right way.
This is one last slide,
talking about the problem
and comparing the US to
other high income countries.
And this slide is perhaps
my favorite slide.
If you were to take anything
from this presentation,
and you want to take one
slide and take it to a bar
when you're talking
to your friends
to sort of start arguments,
it's this one slide.
And there are two axes.
On the x-axis, you
have life expectancy.
I apologize.
You have spending.
On the y-axis, you
have life expectancy.
So what you see with all
the gray bars is that as we
spend more, you get more.
You spend more, higher
life expectancy.
All the other countries
follow that path.
But look at the US.
US falls off the curve,
because we spend more,
and we get less out of it.
So I feel like this
one picture ultimately
tells you what you need
to know is that we are
spending more and getting less.
And we're doing
that in a way that
is in contrast with everything
else, every other sector
in our economy, and
we seem to be doing it
in the sector of
our economy which
matters the most, at least from
a sheer volume point of view--
$3.3 trillion a year.
1 in 8 Americans work in this
business that delivers less
and costs us more.
So having said that and having
made the argument that we
should be talking about
health differently in order
to deal with this problem,
the thesis of the book
is what we need to talk about
when we talk about health.
And the book has
20 chapters in it.
They're all brief,
digestible chapters.
And what I want to do here is
just talk about three of them.
I'm just going to tell you
about three of the chapters
and three of the
things that we need
to talk about when we talk about
health that I think can remedy
this sorry state of affairs.
Number one.
Number one is perhaps
the most important one,
which is we need to be
talking about health
and not talking
about health care.
Now, I suspect it's
one of those statements
that I'm making that
everybody watching is
nodding and thinking to
themselves, yeah, OK, I get it.
But before I even tell
you how to talk about it,
I'm going to pose a
challenge to you all.
Next time you have
a dinner party,
or you're at a bar with
friends, start a conversation
about health.
You can do anything you want.
You can say, I went to a
talk, and I heard something
about health.
And as you do that,
take out your watch,
so you can look at the time.
And see how long
it takes anybody
in the conversation to
use the words health
care instead of health.
And I promise you it will
take less than five minutes.
Always happens.
Within five minutes,
somebody will say health care
when instead they mean health.
And I'm giving
you that challenge
to illustrate how
much we conflate it,
how much we conflate
health and health care.
Now, let me explain why
this matters so much.
I'll start with this.
This is a story of a blues man.
For any of you who are
watching or in the audience who
like the blues, you'll
recognize Blind Willie Johnson.
Blind Willie Johnson
is recognized
as one of the blues greats.
We don't have many of his songs.
Only about 36 of his
songs are recorded.
He was born in Texas at the
turn of the 20th century, which
was 1900s.
And he was born sighted.
And the story is that
when he was seven,
his stepmother threw
lye in his face
in a domestic violence incident,
and he became blind, hence
Blind Willie Johnson.
He grew up poor,
black, blind, in Texas.
He learned how to
play the guitar,
and he made a living busking
on street corners, which
as you can imagine is not
a particularly good living.
He got married.
Him and his wife were
living in a house.
The house burned down, and
they didn't have any money,
so they actually-- when the
fire settled, they went back
and they lived in the husk
of the burnt out house.
When he was 40, he developed
malaria, which now we're
dealing with in 1940s Texas.
Malaria was not uncommon.
He developed malaria, and his
wife took him to hospital.
And he was turned away from
hospital, and then he died.
It's not clear if he was
turned away because he was poor
or because he was blind
or because he was black.
Now, I tell you
this story to ask
a very simple question, which
is, what killed Blind Willie
Johnson?
Well, what killed
him was malaria.
He went to hospital, he had
malaria, did not get treated,
then he died.
So what killed him was malaria.
Had he received treatment
for his malaria,
he would have lived.
Had he receive chloroquine,
But the reason I tell the
story-- it's an extreme story
intentionally-- is
because it's pretty clear
that it wasn't just malaria that
killed Blind Willie Johnson.
It was also homelessness and
poverty and racism and access
to care and domestic violence.
All of these forces also
killed Blind Willie Johnson.
And it's hard to
avoid them when you're
faced with a story like that.
So the difference between
health and health care
is health care is what we
do when we get malaria--
it's treating our malaria.
And I want to be very clear,
this is not an anti health care
argument, not at all.
There's not an anti
medicine argument.
When I have malaria, I want
to be treated properly.
When you have malaria, you
want to be treated properly.
This simply says that health
care, treating malaria,
is different than
what causes health.
And what causes health
is everything else.
It's housing.
It's economic opportunity.
It's education.
It is domestic violence
or lack thereof of.
It is access to care.
It is racism, social supports.
That's ultimately
what causes health.
And that's the difference
between health and health care.
The fundamental reason why
our health is terrible,
despite our investment,
is because as I said,
we spend $3.3 trillion,
and we're spending that all
on malaria, not malaria per se.
I'm using malaria as a metaphor.
We're spending it all on
treating people who are already
sick, rather than
spending enough of it
on the other pillars
that generate health.
So the number one thing
that we need to talk about
is health, not health care.
We need to talk about how it
is that we generate health
so that we can collectively
invest in what generates
health, not just in health care,
not just in what cures disease.
This is just a simple way, now,
of showing this graphically,
just with data.
The bar on the left shows
roughly what causes health.
The bar on the right shows
what we spend our money on.
So if you look at the bar on
the left, the green bar, which
is access to
care/medicine, most experts
suggest that that causes
about 5% to 10% of our whole;
genetics maybe 20%; our
environments, where we live,
our social interactions, our
physical environments 20, 25%;
our behaviors, our eating,
our drinking, our sleeping,
our smoking, 30% to 40%.
And the orange is sort of
a bit of everything else.
But the key here is the mismatch
between the bar on the left
and the bar on the right.
All our spending is
on the green, which
is medicine and health care.
But the green causes
5% to 10% of health.
So health care versus health
is the fundamental tension
that ultimately underlies
why our health is not
as good as it should be.
And it is at core if
I were to be asked--
I'm often asked what's the
one thing you would do.
It is to change our
national conversation
so that we understand
that malaria matters.
But if we only treat
malaria, Blind Willie Johnson
is still going to
die, because he
may be saved from
his malaria today,
but tomorrow he's going to
have pneumonia, or the day
after, he's going
to die from sepsis.
So treating the malaria
alone doesn't do it.
Second argument.
We choose to be healthy
much less than we think.
Now one of the counter arguments
I get to the first one is OK,
health, not health care, fine.
I get it.
I get that housing and
economic opportunity
and poverty and employment,
I get those things matter
for health.
But at the end of the
day, I may be charitable,
and I might not care for
people who are disadvantaged.
Blind Willie Johnson
had a hard life.
But you know what, I can
choose to live a good life.
I've pulled myself
up by the bootstraps.
I can choose to be healthy.
And as long as I
choose to be healthy,
surely I'm going to be OK.
And this is a mistake
that we make all the time.
And in fact, if you go
to a physical bookstore--
I know people here
at Google, which
means that the physical
world is a thing of the past.
But you can go to a
digital bookstore.
You'll find the same thing.
There are two kinds
of books about health.
There are shelves
and shelves of books
that tell you about how you
can choose to be healthy,
how you can choose to eat
better, to exercise more,
to sleep more.
And then you have
shelves and shelves
of books that tell you,
well, if that doesn't work,
here's a pill for you.
Those are roughly the
two kinds of books.
One is how you can
choose to be healthy
and the other one
is well, if that
doesn't work, let's give you
a pill, let's give you a drug,
let's treat your malaria.
That paradigm
suggests that we think
that we can choose
to be healthy,
and that ultimately, our choice
of health is within our hands.
Now, I know you're thinking,
well, but isn't it?
So let me just use a metaphor
to illustrate how it's not.
And I'll go to sort
of a well-known health
movie, "The Devil Wears Prada."
So "Devil Wears Prada," for
those of you who have not
seen it, is a movie about a
fearsome fashion editor who's
played in the movie by
Meryl Streep, and the intern
was played by Anne Hathaway.
And it's a lovely
story of an odd couple
who eventually come to
understand each other and all
that.
But there's a great
scene, which is
the scene which is on the
right, which is where Andy.
the intern, is wearing a
sweater, this sweater here.
And the scene is where there
is a conversation between her
and the editor around--
where the editor is trying
to choose one of two belts.
And Andy, the intern, who
thinks she's bigger than that,
laughs at the absurdity
of the choice,
saying, well, the two belts
look exactly the same.
And the editor, Miranda, decides
to take her down one notch
and says, well, look at
the sweater you're wearing.
You think you chose that
sweater, didn't you?
But what you don't know is that
that sweater is not turquoise.
It's not blue.
It's not lapis.
It's cerulean.
And the reason you're
wearing a cerulean sweater
is because in 2002 Oscar
de La Renta showed cerulean
on the runway.
A few years later,
Yves Saint Lauren
showed cerulean military
jackets, and the five years
after multiple designers
that were using cerulean,
and then that eventually
filtered down into the sweaters
from which you chose.
And the value of that scene--
and I would encourage anybody
to go on YouTube and watch it--
is it makes it very
clear that something
that we tend to
think of as personal,
as much as what you're wearing,
you choose what you're wearing,
is ultimately shaped by the
world around that, that Andy's
choice of a cerulean sweater--
yes, it was her choice,
but it was her choice
from a very
constrained choice set
that was created for her
by the world around her.
And this is the
world that now we're
beginning to [INAUDIBLE] to.
It's a world of physical
choices made for us,
algorithmic choices made for us.
And the world's
always been like that,
and the world's always
going to be like that,
and this is not an
argument against that.
It's simply an
argument that says,
once we recognize
that, then we should
make sure that our
choices privilege health,
that our choice set
privileges health.
And unless we do that,
we are bound for failure.
So the positive is once
you recognize this,
let's create choice sets
that privilege health.
And if we do not do
that, we are going
to have the kind
of conditions we
have in the United States today.
Now, we have done
this before, and there
are good examples of success.
Perhaps the biggest
example of success
is one of the biggest
health triumphs
in this country in the
past century, which
is our decline in
motor vehicle deaths.
So the blue line going down
is deaths from car accidents.
The green line is
how much we drive.
We drive much more, we die less.
Per vehicle mile driven,
we die about 200 times less
for every vehicle mile driven.
We have earned for ourselves the
freedom from dying unexpectedly
in our cars.
Now, how do we do that?
Well, if choosing people to
be healthy was the approach,
we would have done
not by choosing
to create healthier drivers.
Now, I'm from Boston.
I'm not from out here
on the West Coast.
So I'm not sure what drivers
are like in West Coast.
But I can tell you
that in Boston, people
are not better drivers than
they were 100 years ago.
No.
But everybody knows
how we've done this.
We've done this through agreeing
on seat belts and airbags
and shatter proof
glass and incentives
against the driving while
under the influence of alcohol.
That's how we've done it.
So we have created a
world where the choice
set of healthy driving is now
constrained in the direction
of not hurting each other.
That's how we've done it.
And that really has to be
the metaphor for how we
create health in all aspects.
Point three.
If you really buy this argument,
and perhaps the comment
that I'm faced most often since
I've done this book when I talk
to different audiences is well,
this argument you're making
is kind of obvious.
And I actually really
enjoyed this comment,
because I feel like
the arguments are
obvious it means it's
intuitive, which means
we can actually act on it.
We need to understand that
it's the world around us that
generates health.
And in order for
us to be healthy,
we need to actually invest
in the world around us.
And I want to tell you
a story to explain that.
And this is a picture of
what a couple of years
ago was the best soccer team
in the United States, which
is the US women's
national soccer
team that won the World Cup.
Now, soccer is the only
sport I care about.
So this is a very
personal story.
But I understand that
people in the audience
may or may not know
this and other people
from outside the
US would call it
football, which
is its real name,
but for those who don't know
the sport, it's very simple.
You have 11 people on one
side, 11 on the other side,
and they sort of kick the
ball with their feet, hence
it's football, and try to get
the ball to the other net.
That's how the game works.
It's a very simple
game, which is
why it's the most popular
game in the world.
Now, if you don't
know the game, just
understand the 10
players in blue,
they can only use their feet.
The one player in
red, she can use
all parts of her body to stop
the ball from going to the net.
So if you don't play soccer,
sometimes the mistake
that we make is to say, well,
if you have the world's best
goalie, you're
always going to win,
because she can stop any
ball from going to the net.
But if you watch a
professional soccer game,
what you'll see, what we would
see here with Hope Solo--
she's now retired.
The goalie prowls her
area for the entire game,
and she's yelling at
the other players.
You know what she's
yelling at them to do?
She's saying keep the
ball away from me,
because the good goalie
knows that the net is big.
It doesn't matter
how good she is.
A fastball coming at the
net is going to go in.
Now, why am I telling you this?
I'm telling you this, because
you want a good goalie.
But a good goalie by herself
does not win the game.
The goalie is medicine.
The goalie is health care.
The goalie is what we have to
look after us if we get sick.
And we want a good
goalie, right?
As I said at the
beginning, I want
to be treated for my malaria.
I want to be treated
for my heart attack.
But the goalie by herself is
not going to win the game.
You need the other 10 players,
and the other 10 players
are the places we live, the air
we breathe, the water we drink,
the food we eat.
They are whether the
environment around us
encourage us to smoke, use
substances, the houses we live
in, the parks that we
have for recreation,
the education that we
have that teaches us
and put us on a path
towards healthier
living, the economic
opportunities we have,
whether or not there is
violence that we're exposed to,
equity between genders.
Those are the pillars that
ultimately generate health.
And that's what
creates the soccer
team that wins at health.
And what are those pillars?
Here's examples, early
childhood education.
We can spend $5.
We know that we save $5
for every dollar we spend
on early childhood education.
We reduce crime, child
maltreatment, teen pregnancy.
We know this.
Public transportation.
We know that in the city
of a million people,
a 40% expansion
of public transit
has an annual health benefit
of more than $200 million.
And incomes, we know that
things like earned tax credits,
increasing earned income tax
credits for low families by 10%
reduces infant mortality
by 23 per 100,000,
or put another way it saves 23
infant deaths for every 100,000
infants born.
So we know this.
I'm just showing you
three concrete examples.
And these are data you
can find on the web.
You can actually
go on CDC website,
you'll find these data.
These are all from
the CDC itself.
And we know that investment
in these other 10 pillars
ultimately generate health.
And what we keep forgetting
is that investing
in these other 10 pillars
is non-discretionary.
We actually have no choice
but to invest in them
if we want to generate
health, as is perhaps
evidenced by the abysmal state
of health in this country,
despite the extraordinary
investment that we make,
because all that
investment is going
on just one of the
players, namely the goalie.
So the bottom line, so
here's the bottom line.
Here is the takeaway
from this presentation
and really the
takeaway from the book.
I would urge us all to
remember three things.
Three things are as follows.
Number one.
What killed Blind
Willie Johnson?
What choices we
are really making?
And why we need to invest
in more than the goalie?
What killed Blind
Willie Johnson was
the combination of
circumstances in his life
that generated health.
It was housing, poverty, racism,
domestic violence, poor access
to care.
The choices we
are really making,
we think that we are choosing
our healthy behaviors.
But in fact, our
behaviors are constrained
by that same world
around us that ultimately
killed Blind Willie Johnson.
And number three, if we
want to create health,
we need to invest in
much more than malaria,
much more than the goalie.
Once we understand that,
I think it fundamentally
changes how we
talk about health,
and it puts us on a path
towards a much healthier world.
And I will stop with
just one last slide,
and then I'll take questions.
This is what the book's
trying to get at,
and really, the
point of the book
is the subtitle, which is
"What We Need to Talk About
When We Talk About Health,"
because what I'm trying
to do with the book is I am
trying to say we need to change
our conversation on health.
Once we change the
conversation on health,
a lot of other things follow
and our fundamental problem
right now is that
we do not understand
Blind Willie Johnson's story.
We do not understand
"Devil Wears Prada."
how soccer is played
and how soccer can actually
help us win at health.
That's it.
I'll stop there.
I will take questions, comments.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much, Dr. Galea.
I think in your book,
you also touched
on how unique the American
culture is around individualism
and about individual choice, and
you just touched on it as well
during your presentation.
Is health and this fixation
on the individual choice
and individualism
fundamentally contradictory,
because I think it
seems like there
is some kind of
fundamental assessment
that we have to do
amongst ourselves?
SANDRO GALEA: Yeah, it's
a terrific question.
The answer is I don't
think they are at all.
I don't think Americans are
any different than the Irish,
the Italians, the
Swedish, the Zambians.
I think at core, Americans
want to be healthy.
I think we make a mistake
in the American conversation
in this notion of
we want freedom.
It's part of the national
conversation, freedom.
Freedom is a core part of
what it is to be American.
But when you look carefully
at the canonical texts,
at what started
the country, there
are different kinds of freedoms.
There's freedom to do
things, and there's
freedom from things.
And in the past 30, 40 years,
we have privileged freedom
to over freedom from.
You want freedom from
dying unexpectedly
when you leave this building.
That is a freedom.
You want freedom
from getting obese
without thinking about it,
because you're constantly
eating calorie dense,
nutrient poor foods that
are there because of
subsidies for products
that are unhealthy.
And that is also freedom.
So I do not think
it's in contradiction.
I actually think that we
have allowed ourselves
to get into a place where we
privilege one type of freedom
over another, and
I think it's simply
a mistake in our
national conversation.
AUDIENCE: I am curious to
hear your views on drug
decriminalization
in light of what
you said about choice sets and
things to motivate behavior.
SANDRO GALEA: Yeah.
I think the moves towards
drug decriminalization
are enormously long overdue.
The criminalization of
drugs in this country
has had such a
disproportionate effect
on people of color,
particularly young black men,
that it has created a whole wave
of incarceration and downstream
consequences, that I actually
think that still haven't fully
come to grips with the
full scale of the physical
and mental health consequences
of incarceration, which
is directly linked to
criminalization of drugs.
So I think decriminalization
is long overdue.
I also think that
decriminalization,
leaving aside now the
burden that criminalization
has imposed upon a
particular group,
decriminalization creates an
opportunity for regulation.
It creates an
opportunity for drugs
to be purchased and sold in
a way that controls them.
It creates an opportunity
for us to create a system
where the ingestion of those
drugs happens in such a way
that people are not
hurting themselves.
And that, of course, is
something we can never
do if drugs are criminalized.
Now, the argument often about
decriminalization is well,
people can still
buy drugs illegally.
That's true.
But there's ample
historical precedent
to show that most
people most of the time
would rather do things
that are legal than do
things that are illegal.
Once you decriminalize
drugs, people
will be buying those
substances through legal means.
So thank you.
It's a good question.
AUDIENCE: I'm going to
paraphrase a virtual Dory
question.
So this person is saying
that a similar approach needs
to be used regarding our justice
system in mass incarceration,
also contributor to
mortality health,
we focus on eradicating
crime, AKA, disease,
rather than creating strong
safe communities, AKA, health.
So I guess I wanted
to kind of phrase
them more in a question
of what role does--
should community
take a broader role,
or do you think it's really just
like shaping the conversation,
shaping the national rhetoric?
SANDRO GALEA: It's an
excellent question.
I think the answer
I should give is
to say that community
should take a role,
but I want to be
careful when I say that.
I think it's just
too easy an answer.
To paraphrase Margaret
Thatcher, of all people, it's--
Margaret Thatcher said-- she
meant it differently obviously,
but she said, "There's no
such thing as community.
There are only people."
And I actually think that there
is some cynical wisdom to that,
because community is us.
Community populations
are collections
of people that have their
own emergent properties
and behave differently
than individuals do.
But they do remain
collections of people.
So I do think that
communities behave in a way
that its constituent
citizens, us, push
the conversation forward.
You know, there is a
recent set of papers
that talk about what percent
of people in a given country
do you need to
create real change,
and the science seems
to be [INAUDIBLE]..
If you have more
than 3.5% of people
who would demand real change,
change always happens.
3.5% the US is 10
million people.
It's not that many people.
So I do think that this rests
on a national conversation
shift and a global
conversation shift.
For those of you
who are following
from other countries who
are feeling smug about it,
it's probably not so wise,
because unfortunately, there
are abundant examples, national
examples out of countries that
are following along the path
that the US has paved on this.
And the US path is
definitely not enviable.
So I do think that it
comes down to people.
It comes down to citizens.
It comes down to citizens
demanding health and citizens
understanding health
and demanding health
by demanding that we build the
structures to generate health.
AUDIENCE: A lot of people
sometimes are skeptical
of experts like
you, because there
has been a lot of distrust
of experts and of facts,
and because I think a lot of
people presently in poor health
and in poor situations
can only help
but view that essentially people
who are in positions of power
failed us.
And I fail to trust people who
spout knowledge and expertise.
I'm sure that's part
of the reason why
there are many
parents who refuse
to vaccinate their children.
Is this potentially related?
Could you speak on this?
Because I think there would be
a lot of people who would say,
well, they're just trying to
tell me how to live my life.
SANDRO GALEA: Yeah.
So I think it seems to me
appropriate to be a suitably
skeptical of experts.
That's fine.
That seems reasonable.
I think, taking the
American lens for a second,
the American woeful
underperformance on health
has had deep and
devastating consequences
for the national
political scene.
And by that, I don't mean
as a partisan comment.
I mean it in terms of fracturing
the national political
conversation.
So I could show you data,
which I have on my laptop--
I'm not showing it here--
that looks at the
counties in the US
that lost life
expectancy up to 2016.
And you could
correlate those data
with the counties in the US
that were likeliest to vote
for Donald Trump.
And it is a dose response
is a straight line.
The counties that
lost life expectancy
were more likely to
vote for Donald Trump.
Now, if you think about it--
and I hope this is not taken
as a partisan comment--
you had two candidates running
in the last US election.
One candidate, who was the
party of the incumbent, who
essentially said,
we're doing well.
And we're going to do better.
And the our candidate, who
said, I'm not a politician.
I don't like anything
that's happening.
I'm going to change all that
and throw everything out.
Now leaving aside how you
feel about both candidates,
leaving aside their
personal characteristics,
it seems to me that if
you are living in a county
where you've seen your
life expectancy go down,
it is not unreasonable to
vote for the candidate who
says everything is going
to hell in a handbasket,
I'm going to change all of
that, whether you believe
that he can actually do it,
whether or not he's actually
done it is irrelevant.
So the point I'm making is that
our health underperformance
has had seismic impact
on the American political
conversation, and
in many respects,
this trickled down to the
global political conversation.
So I do think that there
is hell to pay for the fact
that we have let
this sneak up on us.
And we are, I should
be clear, today
in a worse position
than we're in when
I started to write this book.
So I'm not sure how many
viewers will know this,
but in 2018, 2017, 2016,
there was a decrease
in life expectancy in the US.
That was the first time
we had a year on year,
three-year decrease
in life expectancy
since the 1918 flu pandemic.
So for 100 years, we have not
had the poor health indicators
that we're having now.
So it is reasonable-- it is
very reasonable for people
to say I don't trust experts.
This is where they got us to.
We are in not a good
place on health.
Having said that, the reason
we're not a good place
is because we collectively
are not talking
about health the right way.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
coming to speak, Dr. Galea.
I had a question regarding
the bar charts that you
had comparing the contributing
factors to our health outcomes
and the amount of spending
that we have on health care.
I believe the largest
contributing factor
was personal health choices
in terms of health outcomes.
My question for
you there is, one,
how did you determine
that that was the largest
contributing factor, or
that overall chart overall.
And secondly, what do you
think are the obstacles
or what is hindering
people in terms
of finding the information
they need to make a better
personal health choices?
SANDRO GALEA: Yeah,
so the calculation
of those percentages is
always very difficult.
It's a [? trivial ?]
fraction calculation.
It ultimately blurs the fact
that these are multiple causes
that all occur and all
contribute at the same time.
So we have to be
careful about being too
rigid in saying it's 30%, 32%.
I would think of
it more as a way
to organize our
thinking about what
the major contributors to
health are because ultimately,
personal choice,
as I've indicated,
are nested within the
environments, which we are in.
So saying that you choose
to eat healthy food
is ultimately directly
driven by the fact
that you're surrounded
by healthy food,
so the two are not separate.
The information I think
is critical in terms
of health behavior,
but it is necessary,
but nowhere near sufficient.
And I think one
of the mistakes we
make in our digital conversation
and in our being enraptured
by all things digital is that
we think that information
by itself is sufficient.
It's simply not.
And there is abundant
data on that.
I can show you,
for example, data
that there's been a wave of
personal genetic testing.
And one of the premises
of it is that, well,
if I know what's on
what my genotype is
and what are more
at risk for, I'm
going to change my
health behavior.
The data are pretty
clear, it doesn't happen.
Actually, I do not change
my health behavior.
So information is necessary,
but nowhere near sufficient.
So this is, again, it's
a bit of an and argument.
It's not an argument
against information.
It's not an argument that
says we need structures that
create stable healthy behavior
sets, versus information,
not at all.
I think we need both,
but information by itself
is not enough.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SANDRO GALEA: Just to
your right, I think.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
the wonderful talk.
I had two questions.
One is I was curious how
the bar charts might appear
in other countries
that are doing
sort of better on a smaller
portion of their expenses?
SANDRO GALEA: Yeah, the
contributing factors to health
don't change.
They're human universal.
What does changes is what
countries spend their money on.
So I've said in this talk
consistently that we spend more
on health than other countries.
It would be reasonable for
you to say that that's wrong.
We actually don't
spend more on health.
We spend more on health care.
When you look at our spending
on these other pillars
that I'm talking about, which
is the housing, the education,
the economic opportunities,
when you look at that spending,
we far underspend our peers.
So when you add those two, if
you take my soccer metaphor,
and you say what are we
spending on the whole team,
we are spending substantially
less on the whole team
compared to countries that
do much better than we
do on health.
So in some respects, the
spending and the outcome
is well matched.
AUDIENCE: So on the left side,
that would have been unchanged,
relative to other countries.
The right side, they
would have had more than--
instead of just 5% on the
bottom on other factors,
that would have been higher.
SANDRO GALEA: Correct.
AUDIENCE: My second thing I was
curious about is to what extent
do you find it useful and
informative to break down
the US into different, say,
socioeconomic categories
or something and how do the
curves look if you do that?
Is that a useful--
SANDRO GALEA: Yeah, it
doesn't change very much.
Now, there are many different
socioeconomic patterns
across the country.
And in fact, there's
been some papers
that have been done dividing
up the US into eight
different groupings of states.
There's many
different ways which
we can divide up the country.
But the things that don't
change are as follows.
Number one is in terms of those
two bars you're referring to,
what causes health
doesn't change,
and what we spend on
health does not change.
I live in Boston
in Massachusetts,
and Boston is the city in the
country which has the highest
doctor population ratio.
It is a city where health
is the primary employer.
So sometimes, I give a
talk like this in Boston,
and I get challenged on that.
Well, surely Boston
is different.
And I can show data
in Massachusetts
that shows in the past 15 years,
we have increased our spending
on medical care by about 80%,
and we have kept the same
or decreased our spending
on parks and recreation,
on mental health, and
public health efforts,
on criminal justice,
domestic violence.
All of that's gone down
or stayed the same.
So even in Massachusetts,
which by the way,
I mentioned Hawaii is
the healthiest state.
Massachusetts the
second healthiest state.
So even in Massachusetts, we
are underperforming this set
of factors, which explains why,
even Hawaii and Massachusetts
have worse health indicators
than, say, Slovenia and all
the countries above Slovenia.
AUDIENCE: Thanks very much.
SANDRO GALEA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about for each individual.
Should we try out all the
trending diets and health
advice flowing around in the
internet such as the Keto diet,
or should we just stick
to the most basic,
less is more concept,
just being stable?
SANDRO GALEA: I think you
should stick to the most basic,
because the truth about all
these diets is some will work,
some won't.
Some will make a difference.
Some won't.
But the difference
is around the edges.
What really matters,
what really matters
is ultimately the choice
set and the individual
doing eating healthy
consistently over a lifetime.
So going to Keto diet or
the Atkins diet or whatever,
it's sort of irrelevant.
What really matters is that
you eat a variety of things,
you get enough nutrients,
you eat in moderation,
and you do that consistently
throughout a lifetime.
And most humans have
a really hard time
doing that, in large
part, because we do not
surround them with healthy foods
consistently over a lifetime.
So I would say, ignore all that.
Eat reasonably.
Eat broadly over a lifetime.
That's what you need to do.
AUDIENCE: And then just kind
of bring the question home
here at Google.
So in your research,
how have you
found technological advances
playing a part as your bar
charts increase or decrease,
how have you seen that?
SANDRO GALEA: I like technology.
I think technology has
brought some wonderful things
to changing our life, although
it never changes our life as
quickly as we think it does.
Otherwise, we'd be driving
around in flying cars today.
I think the mistake
that we make is
into thinking that
technology is a solution
for fundamental problems.
And this goes a little
bit to my answer
I gave about information being
necessary, but not sufficient.
I think technology is a
terrific adjunct to improving
our quality of life, towards
creating opportunities for us
to live healthy for
as long as possible.
But by itself, it
is not sufficient.
And the mistake that we make is
if we think that technology is
going to be the only solution.
And there's plenty of people
who've written about this.
And I think it requires humility
on the part of all of us
that technology is simply
part of the solution.
At the end of the
day, technology
doesn't know what to do
with domestic violence.
It doesn't know how
to deal with housing.
It's not going to deal with
economic opportunities.
It's not going to deal
with gender equity.
It's not going to deal with
early childhood education.
It's an adjunct to all of those.
But by itself, it's not enough.
So I do think that to
we need to make sure
that we see technology
in its place,
and to go back to
my soccer metaphor,
I think technological
advances and developments that
create opportunities for--
let's call it a more
sophisticated form of living
that allows us to do more--
is one of the players
on the soccer team,
and I'm OK with that.
And I think it's important
that whenever there is a soccer
team, as long as we don't
make the mistake, thinking
that if we invest everything
in player number seven,
player number seven
being technology,
we're going to win the
game, because we're not.
AUDIENCE: So you believe more in
technological aids, rather than
solutions?
SANDRO GALEA: I think
that-- it depends
on what you mean by solutions.
If by solutions--
my argument is not
whether technology
is a solution or not.
My argument is whether it
is a sufficient solution.
So I'll stick with
my soccer metaphor.
I think player seven
can score, but she's not
going to win by herself.
She needs the other 10
players, and technology
is one of the 10 players.
AUDIENCE: I guess to ask
one final question, which
is kind of a good
final question,
this person wants to know what
we at the individual level
can do to help change the
system and the environment.
Is it next time we go to a bar,
like start the conversation?
SANDRO GALEA: Yes.
That's great.
I will give three things.
Number one, yes.
Go to a bar.
Go to dinner.
And tell 10 people
about this talk.
If everybody tells 10 people
and tell them to tell 10 people,
that will get us to the
10 million people who
understand the conversation.
That's number one.
Number two, number two, vote for
candidates who understand this.
Vote for people for
positions of authority
in the public sector
who understand
what it is that it takes
to generate health.
And that could be
at local level,
at the municipal level,
at the state level,
at the federal level.
Number three, be a part of
and support and encourage
the private sector that
is willing to generate
the conditions that
generate health.
So I think those three.
Change the conversation.
Vote for people for public
office who understand us.
And number three,
create conditions
in the private
sector by supporting
elements of the private sector
to understand this discussion.
Thank you to Google for allowing
me to present that message.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much for giving
your wonderful lecture.
SANDRO GALEA: Thank
you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]